this photo it's a town in Austria super
old like people have been mining the
saltier since thousands of years BC the
town sits here nestled in the Austrian
Alps the lake the surroundings it's also
beautiful
maybe you've seen this town in a picture
before I know I have like a million
times
seriously I've seen this photo so many
times it's the screensaver on my in-laws
Apple TV I see it in travel magazines
and no matter the weather I see it on
Instagram it's everywhere this town this
photo rather has become a cliche to me
every photo taken from the same place
from the same angle this place is not a
place to me it's just a symbol a single
dimensional caricature seared into my
brain through so many exposures to this
one angle maybe this isn't the case for
you maybe you've never seen this photo
before but if you like to travel like I
do certainly you have places like this
the spots you always see in photos as
you scroll the places that if you travel
to you would just have to take that one
photo from that one angle that same
angle repeated a million times by a
million visitors so I went to this town
why not sure really maybe just because
it's beautiful maybe I wanted this
classic photo for myself regardless of
the motive as I drove closer to this
place I couldn't quiet this burning
curiosity what is this place
outside of being an Instagram cliche is
it really a quiet village in the Alps as
the photo promises no it's not
this place is called hallstatt it's an
idyllic village that was once known for
salt mining but now the town lives on
only one economy and it's the economy of
people who come here to take this photo
buses of tourists show up here to bustle
through the Main Street on their way to
this spot where they can cram in and
take this picture I think is said it
best it's so darling so crowded so
darling
so crowded so darling Oh
why do you even travel in the first
place what makes you spend your money to
leave your familiar surroundings sit on
an airplane and trek into unknown places
more and more people travel for this to
seek out these iconic places where they
can show that they too are part of the
club but for me travelling for this
would be like buying a beautiful Persian
rug and then covering most of it with a
paint cloth the part left uncover is
beautiful but it's just a tiny piece of
the whole thing it's just on the edge
what if you did things differently if
you decided to break away from the tour
buses and go in any direction from this
town you'll certainly find a quiet road
near a mountain that no one's ever heard
of and then you'll walk through a quiet
forest that no one's ever talked about
on the Internet
[Music]
you'll stay in a cabin far away from any
top destinations list and it'll be quiet
[Music]
you'll drive and drive and you'll go to
towns that you didn't plan on going to
and see beautiful things you didn't
expect to see stuff you've never seen
while scrolling online
[Music]
you'll stop in towns that aren't this
one and you'll eat lunch at a place that
is frequented by people who live in that
town the restaurant and the food that it
serves may not make the best social
content but it'll be quiet more closely
connected to this place these people
you'll probably have a better
conversation here than in a place where
you're fighting with other tourists for
a table
[Music]
you'll take weird turns and go on
adventures not really knowing which way
to turn because there's no guidebook for
this part you'll wander and discover
places that have been forgotten where no
one's pointing a camera lens and it'll
be a buzz a delight you cannot die
[Music]
not this kind of buzz a different kind
of buzz there's always a quiet road
somewhere that needs exploring why not
break away and go explore it now there's
certainly nothing wrong with taking this
picture do it edit it up get those
photos on the internet tell your friends
that you did it you stood in this place
studies show that you get a nice hit of
happy Chemical to your brain when you do
it but when I'm driving on that quiet
road puzzling over the mysteries of this
place their people their language the
mountains the rivers the trees that is
what feeds me in the end
I'm grateful this town exists it's
beautiful its history is beautiful but
this isn't the whole package and in fact
I'm certain that the best parts of a
place life far away from here on your
own quiet road waiting to be explored
[Music]
I want to be clear about something which
is that I'm not trying to judge anyone
here this is not me trying to condemn if
someone enjoys traveling a certain way I
made this video because I wanted to have
a little bit of a reflection for myself
on why I travel and how these iconic
places fit into that and this is the
result so no judgement enjoy your time
and your travel however you want to your
life also I want to say it the music in
this video which I love was produced by
Tom Fox he's a guy who's been making
music for me he's super good and he's he
does the cynthy stuff he does all this
amazing work I'm gonna leave his link in
the description should go check him out
thank you for watching lots more to come
[Music]